ladies and gentlemen Marvel wants us to
forget about that secret Invasion finale
because we got a Loki season two trailer
today John how are you good morning good
morning I'm high key excited for this
how are you I'm doing well look who
decided to show up early and very I mean
wow come on I'm ready to love again wow
here we are with koi so we can talk for
obnoxiously a long time ladies and
gentlemen leave a like and we gotta
sponsored a shout out today to to pay
for this guy being here this time let's
swerve from the path of our regular
content to delve into a realm where
Shadow fights light mythical Champions
become the architects of their own
destiny yes you've called it rage Shadow
Legends it's more than just a name it's
an invitation to a symphony of battles
that would make even a dragon trip in
the mystical expanse of Talaria Darkness
looms under the veil reign of the dark
lord siroth Only You Brave Summoner can
conjure an alliance of Champions to
Vanquish this malevolent a world teaming
with dungeons formidable adversaries and
breathtaking Landscapes is yearning for
a hero from a legion of over 700 unique
Champions across diverse factions you
can craft an army as unique as a phoenix
feather shape them into an unbeatable
force that will make even the stone
golems envious outfit them with
potential artifacts imbue them with
Untold power and let them unleash their
full potential test your steel against
other heroes in the PVP Arena Battle the
great leviathans of the game World the
send the clan rankings and become the
beacon of Glory in the gloaming The Saga
raid is ever evolving witness the terror
the new Phantom General akumori whose
might overshadows even the diarist of
nightmares also if the animated series
raid called The Arbiter Escape your gaze
the complete 10 episodes of way to an
official raid Shadow Legends YouTube
channel sorry Ray to seize a sword of
Destiny and dive into the heart of Rage
Shadow Legends to some of my QR code or
conjure up the link in the description
box to initiate your quest an epic
Champion Drake of the lizardmen faction
along with a horde of other Treasures
awaits you let's weave our Legends
together so don't forget light the way
by hitting my link in the description
box or the QR code on screen and I'll
see you in the Twilight of the
battlefield as the Arbiter watches over
us may you always find victory
[Music]
at least I missed them
obey
hello
we have a little bit of a situation we
wanted to run by you
movie again
wow time slipping wait is this
spider-verse glitch in real life looks
awesome yeah can you fix that no
at least for the time slipping the TVA I
know but we just saw it happen
oh trippy pulled through time
between the past and the present hello
what I saw is true
Sylvie there's nothing to stand between
this world and other destruction hey one
way to find it and girls behind them
little good old-fashioned leg work
listen we have different styles you're a
man of action which is fine
I take a more slow deliberate cerebral
approach
it's really good buy
[Music]
October 6 officially coming saniac it's
up to us
that Sylvia works at McDonald's
[Music]
hey Rafa
oh that was uh yeah yeah make the hard
choice
yeah
always have been always moving
nice A little over the top don't you
think I thought it was spot on
man amount of Adventures are going to be
going on yeah holy moly I've been lying
if I said I did not have nipple chills
right now there's so much excitement I
haven't felt in so long yeah I feel like
a terrible thing of Marvel did not just
air
yes
good feelings without any asterisks or
slight tinge of negativity that I'm
feeling even when I'm out I'm in you
know
all right guys so as much as the MCU has
been a real up and down up and down
Journey with everything and you know
it's hard to find fault with anything
that really showed us here in this
trailer it seems to be carrying on what
we love so much about the first season
of Loki without ruining what's to come
because you got so much off-kilter
Adventures that you're seeing on display
here somebody teases you know Ki Quan
he's bringing that a little Charming
innocence to his character and I'm like
he's so he seems perfect for this and
almost I was like five seconds of him
you know what I mean and you've got
these teases of rivona rensslayer as
well during the time period of when
we're gonna see Victor timely which
feels Comics accurate to John I had you
look up her name beforehand of what it
altered it was what was it Rebecca
tormente don't try to act like you just
didn't look it up I looked it up
Rebecca terminate there just I was
trying to get you I can't remember if it
was actually Rebecca or not it's like a
second like I looked it up a second ago
I should remember it's very early I
couldn't pull the name but yeah with the
Rebecca tormente of when Victor timely
was introducing these kinds of you know
science mechanics to the world and in
the meantime he was also with Rebecca
torment so I feel like we're gonna see
the history there of how she became to
be you know the ravono ren Slayer that
we see in Loki season one who doesn't
have a recollection of these experiences
at least that's what it seems to be
so yeah this is um this this is this is
a great trailer
it's really hard to find fault with
anything right here I'm really the only
thing I'm really like keeping me
apprehensive of just fully surrendering
to it is the fact that Marvel lately has
has been a very like uh
Marvel Disney plus I just don't mess
this up yeah you know what I mean
um John which which what you got what
you got for us today yes yes aside from
the general apprehension of just the way
things have been going this is quite a
dazzling trailer it's got all the timey
wimey stuff that you wanted up here
sprawling and jam-packed like we're
going to have a ton of Adventures that
all seem yeah very grave in terms of
time and bouncing off the Marvels you
know with them doing the whole sort of
you know displacement teleportation
thing and now you've got Loki time
slipping in the TVA and all that stuff
like it looks like it'll add further
layers of sci-fi to the already apparent
on and gallivanting across time and
space and all that stuff yeah man uh
yeah and then like everybody who's back
looks great and I mean you get little
glimpses of like Eugene's in here and uh
other faces you know from uh the TVA I
forget uh you know the guard b129 or
whatever is back like you know I I
really hope they can nail this because
yeah this looks absolutely dazzling yeah
I mean they even who's the guy who in
the first step of Casey is that his name
oh that's the guy like that that does
the uh should we see the first yeah yeah
is it Casey yeah yeah you see Casey
there and he looks like he was
imprisoned or something like yeah he
looks like he's in some Terry Gilliam
yeah he's like in time prison
yeah yeah because we weren't I wasn't
sure whether or not were we watching
that's the great misleading part about
something with the Loki trailer is are
is this the TVA members from the first
season are they different TVA members
are these TVA members carry on is and
they and they don't have a recollection
of are they variants they're exploring
are they meeting them for the first time
or they won't know what they have
context because if I'm not mistaken Loki
season one they they one of the reveals
was that the TVA members they were uh a
variance right yeah yeah and they didn't
know it either they were like so you
might have to meet their original selves
yes yeah so there's so many ways to go
with it and I feel like you know the the
amount of Adventures that we saw teased
here are going to give us more of what
we've kind of wanted from Loki season
one even though I thought that was great
uh but some people did feel a little bit
let down by we didn't get to go enough
places and those people were wrong yeah
I I think this season looks like it
could do the thing that Marvel has
needed to do for a very long time which
is unite all of the timeline elements
and make this Multiverse make sense they
mapped out the Multiverse quite a long
time ago this looks like not only it has
introduce certain Sony elements like the
way the time slipping looks which is
directly pulled from into the
spider-verse but now as a live-action
entity but you get elements that could
would tie in what they're doing with
Deadpool 3 because we know Miss minutes
is going to be a factor this morning
Miss minutes actually shared Allah the
world of this this trailer so we get
certain elements that are going to tie
into what they're doing with the fox
implosion which we assume is going to be
Deadpool because the fox Universe to a
point this could also tie into what they
do next with Madame Webb because this
comes out this October Madam webs out in
February I could see this tying in what
Sony does and like Fox does let's look
at that point
this could be the thing that gets us on
track and their priority we've got to
connect to Matt guys you guys gotta look
here I'ma look here it's somewhere in
the middle we get low-key season two now
this is uh Justin Benson Aaron Morehead
two directors I absolutely adore if you
haven't seen their other work they're
absolute Geniuses and they do so much
really ominous dread so we see a lot of
fun here in hijinks but what I love is
those are our words ominous and dreads
well there's a lot of duplicitousness
but I really think there's gonna be a
great uh a world where we can have all
the humor of having Owen Wilson and Tom
middlestone which is my favorite part of
the first season is just those great
dialogue scenes but with these guys
directing it I'm excited to see what
Victor timely does uh behind the scenes
we see that shot of all the kangs coming
at them through the the scripture wall
like we see a lot of things that talk
about this war so I'm really excited to
see what they bring specifically with
their tone to the Fun World of Loki
which isn't not dark and full of dread
oh yeah
they seem to bring an actual like
Macabre sense of humor to the whole
pitcher because there is a bit of a dark
Glee that it's kind of leaning into now
that we're looking at Sylvie in these
imagery and you know what it is actually
what I just realized about this whole
thing is it seems to actually be a
little bit more like everything
everywhere all at once which is a little
after towards it and there are parts of
Sylvie especially where it seems to me
that she does not have a recollection of
things seemingly yeah new haircut now
McDonald's haircut at McDonald's yeah
but she seems lost like she's at a place
at a time in a lot of ways like this is
not what her identity belongs to just
the looks that she was giving and then
she's slowly finding herself maybe
that's when Loki goes to like pull her
out of it in some way and I'm really not
sure Kang is able to control everyone
else except Loki maybe that's why he's
time slipping I'm wondering if everyone
else has lost that context but he
couldn't trick Loki I also think it's
really interesting that at the end of
this uh in the comic books because of
how popular Loki is you may have noticed
in the greater continuity Loki was a
villain and then Tom Hiddleston is just
so Charming so they actually in the
comics changed him from the broader
definition of god of Mischief to the god
of stories because they wanted to have
him be less of a villain so at the end
of this trailer when he says I'm the god
of Mischief always have been always will
be it seems to be implying that he goes
back to his villainous side so I'm very
curious uh as to what the manipulation
of Kang turns maloki into because he
seems to be the only one that has the
full grasp of what's going on yeah so
John will throw it to you uh Jonathan
majors in the trailer do you think he's
innocent do you think he's guilty should
he be in the trailer let me get it all
to you make it all about that I have all
these all about with that John I think
they should have put more Jonathan
Majors Clips in I think he should have
been most of the dialogue of this
trailer I feel like that's really the
way to just meet things head-on just to
be like hey guys I was hoping we could
just step put this to the side for a
little bit and so then we could just
talk about Kang being here she's gonna
be in here regardless since this was
already done before any of this stuff
went down we're gonna get it but you
have to make it all controversial that's
my that's my goal you know as Marvel
needs to embrace the controversies in
all seriousness I was kind of surprised
that they actually did show even though
it was just a clip from Quantum me they
just show his face he said a line of
dialogue yeah and it was a new one
I still still pretty much the same team
it's the reveal but now with dialogue
yes it's the most acceptable it was it
was a questionable thing of like oh will
they show him well then like regardless
of whether or not you you believe he's
innocent or not right uh it's not even
about that it well it is about that I'm
just saying that we're like it's he's
such a controversial figure at the
moment that I was surprised that we we
did see him but they wanted to give lots
of people thumbnails and then at the
same time it would have been
um uh it would have been controversial
yeah it's a no it's a no-win situation I
think this is about as much as they
could have done because everybody who's
paying attention knows he's in the show
and knows that they can't just go back
and retool the whole thing so I think
yeah just confirming like yeah he's
gonna show up is about as much as you
need for a trailer like this yeah yeah
and then just letting the rest play on
the Intrigue of the mystery and the
mechanics I think it also allows the a
certain element of like who is he for
people that don't follow all the
nitty-gritty of like you see Kang you
see Victor timely it doesn't quite
connect those dots so there is like that
undercurrent of the Imperial Palpatine
behind the scenes which I think is smart
to keep him that way because we don't
know how much he's gonna be in the show
we know he's the big bad but I like that
there's an undercurrent of like what's
happening throughout this trailer yeah
that's the whole vibe of it even with
Mobius I'm not I'm unsure like the way
the the opening images go
because this could be the same Mobius
yeah it could maybe not could not be
difficult but he's allowed to get
haircuts my only criticism no jet ski
but but yeah I think I don't think they
would want to show us that in the
trailer season five I feel like Marvel
MCU trailers today would show us that
but uh
part of the dynamic though that I think
does have a cool flip to it is it seems
that Loki's more leading the way yes on
their Dynamics whereas before obviously
in the last season you know Mobius was
more of the knowledgeable one and more
leading the way for Loki to eventually
find his own identity and throughout the
course of the series but here
it feels like Mobius is more of that
supporting role you know it feels like
they took him seriously at the very end
of Loki season one just by what we're
seeing here is is you know he seems to
clearly be the one who knows how big of
a threat Kang is and also all these
things happening to the timeline being
somewhat directly responsible so maybe
yeah they are just deferring to his
knowledge it's out in two months I'm so
excited I'm excited for it too my one
concern
um oh yeah yeah my only concern that I
really have about it is the fact that
they did change from Kate wasn't Kate
Heron
yeah that is my one concern which you
told me about that change I didn't know
about it until recently and you know it
just read to me like oh a bit of a Scott
Derrickson Doctor Strange situation
where the person who's very very
passionate about the thing they Helm now
had to leave and they brought in someone
else yeah and then sometimes that
different direction that is being
mandated by Studio does not equate
I don't want my location to being yeah
like a transitional building block and
and while these directors are good uh
you know I wasn't a big fan of the Moon
night finale ultimately who's to say if
that was really their fault or not you
know I I S I said I am a bit
apprehensive only because of that and
again because of what the MCU has been
like lately where it could be such an up
and down Journey
but Loki season one was pretty awesome
and and many consider it the best series
out of the Disney plus Library so hope
episode six doesn't end with just
punching stuff
let's see how it goes guys what did you
think about this trailer leave your
thoughts down below
um be sure to leave a like subscribe and
hey we will um let's chat with you all
soon thank you for being here